[Music]
language is an essential part of our
lives that we often take for granted
with it we can communicate our thoughts
and feelings lose ourselves and novels
send a text messages and greet friends
it's hard to imagine being unable to
turn thoughts into words but if the
delicate web of language networks in
your brain became disrupted by stroke
illness or trauma you could find
yourself truly at a loss for words
this disorder called aphasia can impair
all aspects of communication people who
have aphasia remain as intelligent as
ever they know what they want to say but
can't always get their words to come out
correctly they may unintentionally use
substitutions called para phages
switching related words like saying dog
for cat or words that sound similar such
as house for horse sometimes their words
may even be unrecognizable there are
several types of aphasia grouped into
two categories fluent or receptive
aphasia and non fluent or expressive
aphasia people with fluent aphasia may
have normal vocal inflection but use
words that lack meaning they have
difficulty comprehending the speech of
others and are frequently unable to
recognize their own speech errors people
with nonfluent aphasia on the other hand
may have good comprehension but will
experience long hesitations between
words and make grammatical errors we all
have that tip of the tongue feeling from
time to time when we can't think of a
word but having aphasia can make it hard
to name simple everyday objects even
reading and writing can be difficult and
frustrating so how does this language
loss happen the human brain has two
hemispheres in most people the left
hemisphere governs language we know this
because in 1861 the physician Paul Broca
studied a patient who lost the ability
to use all but a single word
during a post-mortem study of that
patients brain Broca discovered a large
lesion in the left hemisphere now known
as Broca's area scientists today believe
that Broca's area is responsible in part
for naming objects and coordinating the
muscles involved in speech behind a
Broca's area is Wernicke's area near the
auditory cortex that's where the brain
attaches meaning to speech sounds damage
to Wernicke's area impairs the brain's
ability to comprehend language aphasia
is caused by injury to one or both of
these specialized language areas
fortunately there are other areas of the
brain which support these language
centers and can assist with
communication even brain areas that
control movement are connected to
language fMRI studies found that when we
hear action words like run or dance
parts of the brain responsible for
movement light up as if the body was
actually running or dancing our other
hemisphere contributes to language to
enhancing the rhythm and intonation of
our speech these non language areas
sometimes assist people with aphasia
when communication is difficult so how
common is aphasia approximately 1
million people in the US alone have it
with an estimated eighty thousand new
cases per year about one-third of stroke
survivors suffer from aphasia making it
more prevalent than Parkinson's disease
or multiple sclerosis yet less widely
known there is one rare form of aphasia
called primary progressive aphasia or
PPA which is not caused by stroke or
brain injury but is actually a form of
dementia in which language loss is the
first symptom the goal in treating PPA
is to maintain language function for as
long as possible before other symptoms
of dementia eventually occur however
when aphasia is acquired from a stroke
or brain trauma language improvement may
be achieved through speech therapy our
brains ability to repair itself known as
brain plasticity permits areas
surrounding a brain lesion to take over
some functions during the recovery
process
scientists have been conducting
experiments using new forms of
technology which they believe may
encourage brain plasticity in people
with aphasia meanwhile many people with
aphasia remain isolated afraid that
others won't understand them or give
them extra time to speak by offering
them the time and flexibility to
communicate in whatever way they can you
can help open the door to language again
moving beyond the limitations of aphasia
[Music]
[Music]
you